so this feels so normal we've got the
fires and everybody's here and it just
feels jovial it's wonderful it's
wonderful
okay remember you're staying six feet
apart we're staying together and yet
apart yeah no it is stressful i'm
supposed to help the kids maintain
this
six feet protocol and i'm just like and
it's so not part of their nature i mean
it's so not normal
not too close truly
mary
will you tell them stay awake ari stay
away from everybody
[Music]
truly if she starts walking towards you
back up
ari
you have got to like keep your distance
from people i keep telling them i'm
trying not to get like frustrated
because i don't want to ruin the
experience for everybody but i'm the one
chasing the kids
that's what i thought was gonna happen
so i'm trying robin i'm trying
arielle is only four years old she gets
to be with solomon all the time the two
of them are out here and then there's
truly who she has to stay away from and
then i have to be away from them as well
that's just not normal kid behavior so
i'm sure it's kind of difficult for him
you just want to keep on playing i know
you want to play but you guys have to
stay distant from each other i'm trying
i'm just this big jerk stay away from
each other you're brothers and sisters
and you love each other but don't touch
each other
i'm trying as hard as i can to follow
the rules okay i am really aware that
you're doing that okay i'm supposed to
be helping you and i kind of checked out
all right
who wants to sit and and abide by these
protocols for four months and then get
sick once because they let their guard
down and i realized that it's a burden
to rob and to be able to do this hey you
guys dayton
dayton and garrison i i need to respect
your mom
ari saul
solomon truly you guys are supposed to
be six feet apart
truly
make sure you keep your distance
you're the best truly's missed everyone
so much she's missed solitary so much
we'll do our best to maintain that but
she's really glad to be here with
everybody it's really nice
[Music]